wake I won’t say anything else
that they dad
set up so that it’s as if our
civilian population reports are all fixes the
real network itself and you watch
TV yes I watch TV ours to
make it
clear to me more photos of
international news agencies
saw
no this I missed it already on  and the
retribution of our entire country will be
very terrible for this Germany is still paying
reparations for another forty-fifth year what
awaits us unknown no I don’t know in
principle the situation in the world is not interested in
teaching yes I saw photographs but here the
locals and I think something
terrible death of ordinary citizens  which is
not guilty of anything,
it’s a fake that it’s more than 2xu, it’s clear
that we ourselves are Ukrainians,
all the information you get from the TV,
the workers, yes, of course, I heard it is, and
the consequences of something happening,
in fact, wants to say a lot,
even screaming unfortunately the ranks of anyone
I will comment because our country with
our freedom of speech and
any comment can be Christy of the
consequences you have to be
silent, it seems to me that this is, in
general, what
Ukrainian TV channels cover, it’s not true, I
don’t believe in simple it’s
me and at night it’s tight from TV
that the Western media is
visible but
no  learn everything is difficult that we are a person
in general it’s difficult to figure it out so let’s tell
me this is my personal opinion it’s a fake it’s not a
fake find out where and from where we can the
media say that this is a fake
Ukrainian, that is Ukrainian,
for some reason our Ukrainian radio stations
turned off, drowned out, that is,
analyze something
we can’t eat their position, it’s very scary and
incomprehensible
[music] I
heard that
our troops left this city, I
have my own point of view on this,
so I’m not ready to share, but there is
one opinion, of course negative, it was impossible
to leave, so let’s say propaganda is working there and there
Naturally, it seems that a beggar is trying to try
his truth, so if you are talking about a specific
case, yes, with people, then it is very
similar that it is not with her, but in my opinion
this is not true,
because what would be the point of doing this at all
when we are distributing humanitarian
aid there  in the cities, and then they suddenly went for
people to the right to the left to kill, it’s
illogical and it seems to me that this is fake, it’s
terrible, of course, I don’t approve of the
death of civilians,
nothing good, but
there, in the Russian media, they always
say that this is propaganda, they themselves
propagandize, they don’t understand what, yes, of
course, but  this is a fake this is an absolute
fake there even the whole lie as if but not
naturally how they should lie here
this fear itself comes from ukraine so
the soul hurts for all
the colors all this staging